so right now i have to congratulate you
on making it finally
as a well-deserved peach holder after 10
seasons uh my question for you is what
was the biggest adjustment for you in
becoming a full-time housewife
the biggest adjustment um
i guess i'll really just say the biggest
adjustment has been filming more at home
my personal life
because i did everything the girls did i
went on every trip as a friend i mean
every you know i was around a lot as a
friend but now it's just more it's in
your face when you wake up like can i
brush my teeth move away
so just the more you know more filming
i'll say
well and you've had to share a lot more
of your life we've seen so much more of
you including you know your your
businesses and your life as a monty and
particularly i mean we just saw you and
your conversation with your sister and
some of the highs and lows you've dealt
with there and you know that's such an
emotional thing to share do you struggle
with what you share on camera what you
give us as a viewer
you know what i really don't i'm an open
book what you see is what you get you
know i don't have no filter i say any
damn thing
and i'm a true believer in living my
truth so i that's why i'm just so
authentic and what you see is what you
get the only concern i had was my
nephews michael and william i was just
like oh this is too much my family are
they gonna be upset and i'm like you
know what you guys this is my story this
is my truth and i'm here to share with
my fans and they deserve it for 10 years
i wouldn't be here if it wasn't for my
fans
i know that's right how do you know if
you feel about being on the show and you
being in your position now
how do i fill in my nephews how do the
nephews feel how do michael and william
feel
um you know i don't really talk to them
about it i think they just go along with
it
sometimes i think they're aggravated
because they're tired of the cameras in
the house and i'm like huh get the
cameras up clean up get in your band or
but it's like now at this point it's
like you know what whatever it is what
it is if your room is junky they're just
gonna be as chunky so really in our
house it's just we just go with the flow
it's nothing staged it's just it is what
it is
right and you mentioned too that
obviously you in the past have come
along with whatever the girls are doing
this year you are kind of on the eve and
keel and so we see more of your
interactions and more your dynamics so
like
watching you with kenya butt heads a
little bit and to me i was surprised to
see you in candy butt heads and i know
that's kind of still playing out there
um do you think that those things can
get resolved do you see yourself getting
back into a good place with either of
them
you know what i'm okay with getting back
in the good place with anyone i just
feel that when you're wrong you're wrong
or if i feel some way well i have to
tell you how i feel and i just feel that
out when it comes to candy just a lot of
people that
and i just can't do that i've known her
longer than all the girls
she's like a sister to me and i don't
give a damn who you are you have great
accomplishments but like i just said
earlier only serve one god and that's
the man up there it's not candy so i
just feel that i'm i'm okay with making
back up with her i don't i'm not even
mad or like that i was upset
but i'll just tell you later i'm telling
you so much but it's okay
well i know you have to save something
for the reunion and i'm excited to see
that because this will be the first one
that you're gonna be in like the full
thing you're not just gonna pop in for a
couple hours you're there for the full
stretch um how are you preparing for
that absolutely
i'm just i don't even prepare for it
it's just i speak the truth
like i said and what you were saying
earlier with the candy and kenya
situation
i don't know if you know but just to
refresh your memory i'm gonna do this
because candy has a lot of followers and
people are so mad oh you're coming at
candy
when candy first was promoting her show
the old lady gang show remember
she was using my name she was telling
what was happening on raw housewives of
atlanta and i was upset because i'm like
hey it's my first season as a peach
holder the trailer has not dropped yet
be quiet only talk about the old lady
gang show so that was one
then two
she gets on what was it what did she do
next that bothered me she went on andy
cohen and andy said hey candy what do
you think of marlo's new business or
archive on a scale of one to ten house
how successful will it be
candy said the 2.5 i was like
it just was like are you serious at 2.5
i mean is that not low
so then that was uh two then three as we
watch our confessionals you know we're
all shady but it's like okay candy how
many times are you gonna talk about me
only sleeping with old white men come on
it's been 10 years so i'm like okay so
you're being shady there too so hey
it is what it is but you know
people can dish it but they can't take
it
well i'm hopeful that we'll see marlo
and candy yams get back to a good place
i'm putting that out there i i know
that'll happen and maybe it takes the
reunion who knows
maybe i don't know that child i'm sure
we're going to sit down and speak on it
at the reunion so i hope you sit down
and speak on it
we're going to speak on that reunion so
you rather be watching
i will be and i know you mentioned la
archive of course and since canada is a
dual language country english and french
um how did you feel i have to ask about
kenya shading the name of how did you
feel about that
i you know what listen
when you have money you can spell it
however you want okay when i went to go
and get that name they approved it and i
paid for it now is it spelled
incorrectly
uh to the my french people of course it
is but guess what it wasn't available so
i went with what i could get and i
wanted little archive it stuck in my
mind i'm like however i can spell it
that's how it's going to be spelled then
so exactly and also i feel like you have
a creative license it's your business
yeah
i'm like i'm not thinking about la
archive it's here to stay and it will be
global so
that part um i also have to ask because
of course your fashion expertise or
style expertise uh we i think are
finally gonna see she by sheree that's
the sense that i get
i personally have been waiting a long
time for this do you think that this is
the time it'll finally stick
you're absolutely going to sushi by
charade this time you are and it's
fabulous and you're going to want to see
you're going to definitely see it
all i know is i'm expecting a pair of
joggers at some point i will be getting
a pair of joggers from her you're going
to get you and whatever else more than
joggers you're going to be excited she
even has more than joggers
i can't wait um i also want to ask you
about uh the ultimate girls trip that's
happening right now with uh phaedra and
eva both part of that are you planning
to watch that at all you have any sort
of curiosity
you know what i'm definitely gonna watch
it i can't wait i think i just missed
the first episode but yeah i'm
definitely going to watch it you know
it's going to be epic phaedra
phaedra park's back i'm i would not miss
it and i love eva
and uh if you were to cast your own
ultimate girls trip across the franchise
who are people you'd love to go on a
little uh get away with
oh if i was gonna cast my own oh my god
i definitely have to take um
oh laura who oh would i take i'll
probably do all the fashion girls i
probably just do erica jane or reed i
even put lisa vanderpump in there um
myself of course um who else
i'm trying to think of who else i'll
bring on there um
i can't think of anyone else who else
would i bring on there just them gotta
beat it
i'll take a fashion trip
exactly
you